Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to the virtual world
I've got my Vive
And I've got my space all set up and ready to go to scare the everliving pants out of me
Because I've got a horror game here called Don't Knock Twice and it's been a long
Long time since I've been back in the virtual w-world... ooh!
hey, I got one heck of a pointer here my wedding ring doesn't seem to fit me quite r- oh
Ah, that is mildly disconcerting. I am completely untethered I've got no strings to hold me down
Wibble D. Wobble D
So what that means is I can go wherever I want to be able to fight the demons at my back
oh, hi you are not smoking before I
I went blind okay, don't you know that smoking can kill you?
Alright, whatever alright. Let's do this
Okay, alright. Hey. Wow you are pretty. What a pretty goat. You got there. You seem to be
bulbous and Oh
Bulbous okay, alrighty, I'm gonna walk slowly towards ya
Calmly like an animal whisperer. I'm just gonna like caress your sweet luscious lip here. We go oh
oh
Ah
I
can walk around to explore well let why let me walk with my human legs ah
Yes whoo
Okay a
Map on and a floor and release the telephone
Blanc
Sure wish those uh
Those cages would stop squawking so I could hear myself think huh that'd be great
Press one to grab note from letterbox all right. Okay. oooh!
What are we have here?
Press to read the note. I'm already reading it
What oh?
I can read it one knock to wake her from her bed twice to raise her from the dead oh
That oh that's... oh that's...
That's unpleasant alright, okay, alright. I think I understand one
Hey wait
Alright here. Let me get something straight here. You want me to knock this door whoa?
Hey fuck off with you, so what but what you're telling me. Is that the whole name of the game is don't knock twice and
You're telling me to knock twice
right?
Right there's no demons in here is there okay? All right. You know what whoa hey whoa easy there
I'll uh... I'll play by your rules
Oh, No?
Yeah
Okay, I don't like that. I don't like that. I don't like that
I don't like that especially a don't like that. I really don't like that okay here we go hello. Oh
I said Hey
All right get in my combat stance just in case anything needs to be
Approached leave me the fuck alone. Chloe. Well am I Chloe or are you?
Okay
That's floaties the phone is now in your pocket. You can grab it in. I don't think it is you know I?
Let me grab hand like I'm just
I'm just gonna grab that phone. Okay. Got it, okay?
All right to my pocket now apparently.
barely stated in the southern edge of Welsh valleys lies a stunning example of understated
Architecture I'm bored already is that going in my pocket? I hope not. let me duck my head in the fire for a second here Oh
Roasting my chestnuts, please no one under there? all right. I better not be no one under there
That's all I gotta say about that. Oh. Yeah, no I was right about my original assumption. I hate that that is awful
Okay, what do we got here? Whoa pick up the candlestick to illuminate your way?
This candlestick ain't lit there's one thing I know about this candle what the Frick was that
Someone got a cold over there? all right well
Whoosh I said woosh all right oh good. I got an achievement for that good thing. I'm so skilled at games
I dropped it
Okay, you know what?
I got me and Lumière here. I'll kick you. Oh, that's a different knock location than I thought it'd be
Why? no, I don't I
Know I said, I really don't want to
oh I see what looks like hair over there, and that's a
Problem I have with you Oh
God oh
Oh god. Oh god. I don't want it. I don't want this. You don't want this. I don't want this
Hello, uh hello
Hey! Okay, fuck off you you a guy drop a candle dickhole dill weed bag dick who's there?
Hello
Okay, who we got? who's squeaking?
Who's squeaking? uh oh, uh oh, uh oh
uh oh, wuh oh
Hello not sure what that is
Okay, I'm just gonna carry on with my day
Hey, yah. Oh well that's in my pocket now.
okay let me go over  to the
uh oh, oh that's not good ah
Hirata
Mole
Okay, okay, all right anyone at this one. Hello. Sorry excuse me, sorry hello?
ooh
Well, that's a weird...
Whatever that was. can I go out the door or something gonna be a whoah
Okay alright that I didn't expect that to just be open
I... Know!
Grandmas at you. Oh boy my phone hello. Why did you turn the power off? I hate you what I don't care
What didi is not playing? Why do you think I care that?
Right now?! oh I didn't I didn't turn the power off. what...
How would I have any control over that Chloe?
Grandma? Oh boy I hate this. Oh, I hate, I hate this. oh, I hate this
ah, oh
This is the worst thing a flu shot? got it. Are you oh what was that ah?
ah
Now
Shut up
I'm a bibliophile. Oh the story behind the artist just
oh
ooh
Okay, I don't like no I'm I don't want no. I don't I don't want that. hello? Is that a ghost baby?
Seems like it might be a ghost baby
Don't open, I can't just I can't figure out oh
ooh.   Ah
Ghost baby. Okay, all right, okay all right sir, man
I don't want any hey- oh I said no I said no
I Said no wait wait hang on wait everybody wait
Okay, go back hang on foosh got it. I'm fighting the darkness
with my powers of light and love
Give me one of you
Bibliophile eh? that's me
Department of Health and Social Services Division of Child lay-
Welfare! Theres not child labor. That'd be a weird department
Foosh man Lumière sure is spreading his seed
Mm
I'm gonna go up big nope on that one there. big nope. big nope. nuh uh.
No, don't have my coat. Can't possibly go out there. Oh boy, and that is not a thing I'm gonna be doing today
There's absolutely not a thing I'm gonna be doing. okay! It's a thing I'm gonna be doing. Here we go! Let's do this thing
Outside you know that's oh
ooh
uh huh
Uh yeah. hate it, okay. All right, hate it. all right, very much why?!
Why though, but why? why oh well, I dropped it, please I really want it. there we go hey who why and Wow
Okay
Hey, I know how to do this now. Wow do I have a thumbs up and that'd be nice?
Whoa hi okay? That's really weird. W- w- what? hi
What
You're gonna dump me again, aren't you, you selfish bitch. wait that doesn't make any sense
Wait what that's not good
I don't
Chloe
what is
What that doesn't?
Wait what?! Chloe that doesn't make any sense? What can't we talk in person? I have a weird man uh
I have a weird mansion. Okay, all right. Okay? What are we up here scooch
scooch scooch your booch
who's in here?
Who's in here?
We'll go back inside. Maybe... ooh that one's open. helloooooooo
I yell into my own house whatever where apparently Chloe is. whoa what the hell? all right?
Well *random mark gibberish*
None of that
That was not me oh
Wow that's
Terrifically broken whoo Schmidt no apparently not okay. You know what oh?
I'll come back later on then. I'll come back later. That's that's no bueno at all. all right all right
Why why? Why would you do that?! don't do that!
Just don't do that whoosh
bibliophile
Mm uh
She dumped me okay, all right
She dumped me all those years ago
And now she just waltzes back into my life and expects to carry on like everything's okay well
It's not. I just wish she left me the fuck alone
She's trying to wow me with her fancy job with a big house, but there's no hiding the truth
She abandon me and can't stop hating for that. We're strangers now
She's not fit to be the mother, a mother and she'll probably to send me back to the homeland tired of me
All right. wait where am I by the way? We're waaaaa- nope. Oh! Hey! Well how about we don't do that?
Hmm
How about we don't do any of what you're thinking of doing and how about  I
go back and light the fire in the fireplace
Can you open okay
ooh. All right, okay, I hate that. Oh blood! great! blood!
Wonderful. Why is there blood? Why would there be that thing that's on the ground there?
I... ask the air oh
that's why I
Hate this everything about this is everything I hate
Ah, okay, all right well, that's um shit. That's bad.
Oh, okay
all right, ah
I
Am officially terrified, so yeah, I'm gonna well leave this one here. I'm scared. I'm legitimately scared
This is terrifying um, but this seems like a longer game, so if you guys want to see more of this. Let me know because
I'll finish it
I will
But I hate it
Very scary so thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you think down the comments below and
as always
See you in the next video
bye-bye